okay so today i'd like to work on the
footwork so
study the forms from who you think you
appreciate
as it goes good in aikido with the ken
and the joe my aim is to teach you the
smaller points the finer points that
are going to help you understand a lot
more about your body
and what you should be doing when doing
[Music]
so i've chosen to wear my boots today
so the feet you need to work hard with
the feet
[Music]
if you have uh ankle weights the heavier
the ankle weights the better you can
train these in the dojo with ankle
weights
or like i am outside in the garden
in the park put ankle weights on
underneath your
key or your trousers or whatever you
have
or get some walking boots heavier the
better
this is a foot stepping with a foot
when we walk we step with our feet
to be good in aikido you need to learn
how to walk with your hips
and only your hips of course your legs
are looking like they're walking
but the whole control panel is at your
hips
so when i walk backwards or forwards
over here wherever i drive
from the hips you can't perhaps see any
difference
as i walk around
but it's my hips if you walk from
the legs you know it's one foot and then
push one foot then push
step back back back
this is the weight of your body on each
step walk from your hips
and you'll walk lighter and faster
lighter and faster
when somebody's striking with the ken
the timing
has to be up
so don't worry so much about what i'm
doing with the ken
you can if you wish but
the foot
this is the hip danger
the head so
by having ankle weights or boot
you're learning how to float the feet
okay
how to float the foot
float the foot
and with the other as with the other
films that
i've made the timing of my foot and
finished hand cut to be the same
try not to try not to have a static body
have a floating body from the hips and
the hips
from the hips from the heads
to the hips and the hips
all right
so even while you're watching
me cut with the can i was only
concentrating on the
on the feet and how i can
move them around and there's another
film in there that you'll notice
i was doing tattoo doors saying
how you move
okay so
this is uh
this is part of the movement that you
need to learn with the
ken or the joe thank you for your time